Hello, Office Ladies Family. Before we get started with today's episode, we have some sad news to share. We do. Our hearts are broken, and our dear Phil Shea has passed away. We just wanted to share that news with you because he was a part of our office family. He was a part of our office ladies family. I was just in touch with Phil recently. We were trading some text messages about Pam's chore wheel. And something I can tell you is just how much he loved sharing his passion, his work with everyone. And he loved that you all took such an interest. He really? All of his props and all of his work. Yeah. It was his pride and joy. And we're so happy that we got to share it with you. Yes.
When I ran into him a few months ago, he told me how much it meant to him that people, unoffice ladies, knew his name, knew what he did. So thank you for being part of our office family and we will miss Phil very much. We will. We love you Phil. Love you. I'm Jennifer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on the office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of the office and give exclusive behind the scene stories that only two people who were there can tell you.
We're the office ladies. Hello! Hello, you guys, guess what I was just doing? As our theme song comes on, we listen to it every time we record. Is that dorky? It is? Dorky gets me in the mood. Me too. And it makes me excited to hop on here and talk about the office.
So we listened to our theme song with you guys. And this morning I decided to dance. I did a little dance. She did. I do that sometimes. Sometimes we mouth the words. Sometimes we do. My dance this morning was two fingers where you're like going, but do you, but do you? Yeah, I did a little shimmy. You did. You shimmy the ladies. I shimmy
the ladies today. And I'm glad we did it. Yeah, because. Oh boy. Uh oh. That's a big sigh. Today. We're completing season eight. Yeah, this is it. This is the last episode of season eight. It's season eight, episode 24. It's called Free Family Portrait Studio. It was written by BJ Novak and directed by BJ Novak. He was wearing a lot of hats.
On this last week of 24 episodes, poor BJ, he must have been so tired. I mean, we were all tired, but I think BJ must have been super tired. This was also my birthday week. Oh yeah. My birthday happened in this week. I bet you were tired on your birthday.
It was tired on my birthday. Oh, but we did the cutest thing for my birthday during this week. We were filming over March 7th, which is my birthday. And you guys got me a cake, which was really, really sweet. And Lee brought my son up to set for the cake and the singing, which was so adorable. And we were doing talking heads at that time. That's what we were set up to do. And so we put my son in the talking head chair.
That's adorable. And they filmed a little bit of him. Oh. I know. And I just wrote to Dave Rogers and asked him if there was any way that he could find that footage. Because that memory came back to me when I was watching this episode.
So he's going to look for it. Somebody has that footage. And somebody at NBC also has because that memory came back to me when I was watching this episode. So he's gonna look for it. Somebody has that footage and somebody at NBC also has when Creed and Ed sang Angela's baby to me. We want these things. Someone at NBC. I know. Get it to us. I just wanted to show them. You did. Get it to us.
Dying it. Are you ready for a summary? I am. Last summary of season eight. Are we gonna do this the whole episode? I'm gonna do it the whole season nine, so just get ready. Oh no, okay, here's your summary.
In an effort to prove his paternity once and for all, Dwight sets up a portrait studio in the office for all of the employees. He's hoping to steal some of Baby Phillips DNA for testing. Yeah. Andy pretends to be down and out, but he has a secret plan to become manager again thanks to David Wallace.
I loved when Nelly calls him like a drunken chimney sweep. Such a good description. Robert California reveals his true identity after Joe Bennett dissolves Saber and Darrell makes his intentions clear with Val. It's a lot happening. Yeah. I have lots to say about their impromptu photo shoot.
We'll get to it. Oh, we got a lot of mail about it, Anne. Uh-huh. Yeah. Are you ready for the last Fast fact number one of season eight? I mean, I guess so. Here it is. Like we said, this was our season eight finale and it marked a number of goodbyes.
We mentioned that BJ Novak wrote and directed this episode. This was his last episode as a writer on the office. He'd been with us since the very beginning. This was also Mindy Kaling's last episode as a writer on the office. He'd been with us since the very beginning. This was also Mindy Kaling's last episode as a writer. She left to start her own show, The Mindy Project. I remember just at the time being like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, you guys can't go. It felt like we were losing our core team
that built and defined the whole show. I call them the originals, the OGs. Mm-hmm. That's what kids say. They say the OG. Oh, not the original. So, you know, Mindy and BJ are going to appear as actors a couple times in season nine, but this ended their time as writers and regulars on the show.
And then Paul Lieberstein was also stepping down as showrunner after this season. Yeah. There was a lot of discussion about who might step into the showrunner position. I dare say there was hubbub, lady. Oh, I think that is accurate. Yes.
Hubbub. Hubbub about the originals. Yes. Leaving. Well, I remember John and I went over to BJ's trailer, hubbub about the originals. Yes, leaving. Well, I remember John and I went over to BJ's trailer and we asked him to please consider taking the show runner position for season nine.
We told him nobody else knew the show as well as he did. We were very, what would you call it? Passionate. Yes, you guys wanted him to stay and he said, We were very what would you call it passionate? Yes, you guys wanted him to stay and he said No, he said no. Yeah, I could tell he was really touched But he said he felt really burnt out. He needed to move on well. I can understand that I know And when you're writing and creating you can't be in a space where you're burnt out. No Another goodbye James Spader. Yes. He was moving on. You know, he'd really just agreed to do the one season. Right. So we were
saying goodbye to him after this episode. We also say goodbye to Saber. Goodbye Saber? Yeah, Saber's no more. Sobre. So we had a lot of goodbyes, but we also had a lot of, oh, hello. Oh, okay. Hello. Oh, hello. Hello again, Senator Lipton. Yes. Hey there, David Wallace.
Yes. Oh, hi, Jerry Miner is Val's boyfriend, Brandon. Hi there, warehouse fellas. Now is this, and Calvin Tenor is Hiday and Glenn? I'm sorry, is this, oh, hello, or is it and Glenn? I'm sorry is this Oh Hello or is it Hi There? Because... Oh, you pivoted. It's all.
It's Oh Hello Hi There! It's Oh Hello Hi There! Hi There! Oh, good to see you again! Top of the morning to you! That's right! Good to see you again! Mike sure as mose who we haven't seen in a real long time.
Yes. Oh is that section done? That section's done. Oh Hello Hi There is done. Yes. And, is that section done? That section is done. Okay. Oh, hello. Hi, there is done. Yes. And the goodbyes are done. Okay. In fact, I'm moving on to fast fact number two. Oh, let's do it. I'm calling fast fact number two reflections. Oh gosh. And you did like the whisper voice.
Reflections. Reflections with office ladies. We got a fan question from Alice in W and Dallas, Texas, who asked, now that you've watched eight seasons of the show, what is your favorite episode so far? I thought that question might kick off our reflections. Well, it's a fantastic question from Alice in. What's up, Big D? Love Dallas.
Just thought I would just shout out Dallas. Shout out Dallas. Gosh, Jenna, that out Dallas. Shout out Dallas. Gosh, Jenna, that's one of those thinking questions. I gave it some thought. I sent it to you. We thought on it, Allison. We thought on it. We sure did. It has been a really wild ride watching this show again. I've just loved it. I've really gained a deeper appreciation as a fan. Yeah. And I have to say there are so many episodes that surprised me that I had completely forgotten about. Or there were some that I totally changed my opinion about.
Like we watched them. Give us an example. Mafia. Okay. I remember when we filmed it, I thought it was so broad and so silly. Right. I thought this is ridiculous.
As a viewer, I just absolutely loved it. It's one of my favorites now. Yeah. I have really enjoyed watching the show evolves. But if I have to be honest, and this is what you do when you're reflecting, you just did that thing where you kind of looked over the top of your glasses a little.
Well, that's my lawyer look. That's when you know I'm serious. Yes. Yes. Serious. I thought season eight was a little clunky. I did. Everyone. I know that we were trying to find our way after Steve left and I think you can tell. Well, you're doing that thing where you say something you don't think is 100% going to be received well in you whispering.
Yeah, I think here's your bless her heart. It's my blessing. Yeah. Yeah. I mean season eight plus it's heart. Plus it's heart. I think it started well. I would say I think it's ending
like feeling like strong. In strong. Yeah. turf war and free family portrait studio. We feel like we're back in the zone there. I think. But I think we took a real crazy detour around pool party. Oh yeah.
And then things got real kind of spotty. That said, I do think there are a lot of wonderful moments in season eight that are truly classic. Big Pregs, little Pregs. Love that. Josh Groban and Garden Party. Oh, yeah. Jerry Minor is Brandon.
Perfect. Need him to be a series regular. Sad that he's not. Also, we had unbelievable. Unbelievable bed bugs. Oh, bed bugs. We had smug bed bug. Yes, I thought Jim's presentation at Test the Store.
I had forgotten about that, loved it. But like I said last week, I really understand why people start over and rewatch. I think that the show has evolved very subtly over the many seasons, and I really wanna go back and see people from before. I wanna see Michael again. Yeah. I wanna see Old Jim.
I wanna see Dwight Nangela and their romance unfold again. Yeah, that's such a good point. You know, like you said, I have this new appreciation for the show in a way that I didn't when we were filming it, even though I was a big fan of the show when we filmed it. But now I have an appreciation of the fandom of the show. And what I mean by that is when we first started this rewatch, so many people would come
up to us and tell us how many times they'd watched the show all the way through. And it's many times. I mean, you guys have really watched the show all the way through. And it's many times. I mean, you guys have really watched the show. And I realized there were so many episodes, I mean, whole seasons that I hadn't seen since they aired. Yeah. So I have this new appreciation for the fandom because like what you were just saying,
we're coming to the end of this rewatch and I find myself just so desperately wanting to go back to season one. Me too. It's emotional and it's comforting the end of this rewatch and I find myself just so desperately wanting to go back to season one. Me too. It's emotional and it's comforting to go back to those seasons. And you know, I was thinking about which episodes were my favorite and I know I have my go-tos that I've always liked, like dinner party, things like that.
But in my rewatch, kind of like you with Mafia, a few that snuck up on me, that I just forgotten about with like the deposition, for example, love it. Every moment in that deposition when Michael's being cross-examined is just hilarious. I forgot about Scone's E-Sider. Oh, I forgot about Scone's E-Sider too! And the christening, you know, but I do. I find myself wanting to go back.
I want to see the first party planning committee meeting. I want to go back to all of that. Well, when we talked to Billie Eilish on the podcast, we asked her about rewatching. And I kind of think of her as a rewatch expert, because she's really has seen it so many times. And we asked her, do you ever skip anything? You know, do you have favorite seasons?
Will you just start with a certain thing? And she said no. She said she always goes back to the very beginning and she watches everything. Although she did say sometimes she skips Scott's thoughts. Well, you know, the only one that's okay. It's okay. I think I would have to skip the one about the family paper company. Oh, yeah.
That they closed down. They put out a business. Yeah. Prince Family Paper. Prince Family Paper. That one, I couldn't take it. Oh. But Allison, fantastic question.
It clearly made Jenna and I think a lot about this rewatch and what it's meant to us. And we both want to start back at the beginning. We do. But don't worry, we will cover season nine. Yes, yes, first. Not to get ahead of ourselves. All right, fast fact number three is a fan question
from Curtis G. and Seattle. I didn't think there was anything else that we could learn, Angela, about. I don't know, the origins of characters or anything, this long into our rewatch, but Curtis has found something that I didn't know. The origins of characters or anything this long into our rewatch, but Curtis has found something that I didn't know. What? Here's what Curtis said. When I was in grad school, one of my professors was named Andy Bernard. There was a rumor that he and Greg Daniels were friends in college and that Greg named Ed's character after him.
Is it true that Andy Bernard on the office is named after Professor Andy Bernard at Dartmouth? I would not be surprised at all because Greg liked to do that. Well, I asked Greg, what do you say? He said, you can tell Curtis G that it is completely true that Andy Bernard on the office is named after Professor Andy Bernard at Dartmouth.
However, Andy and I and our mutual friend Jim Halpert have been great friends since first grade. So Greg's two childhood friends are named Jim Halpert and Andy's son are. Yeah, I knew Jim Halpert same, but oh my gosh. Greg said that it was really fun for him to give the characters his old friends names. He never thought that people would still be asking about it 20 years later. Greg also said the real life Andy Bernard is at Dartmouth, which is Cornell's big rival,
and that the real Andy Bernard is not much like the character of Andy Bernard. Well, I should think not. He did say he thinks the real Andy Bernard might have had one of those preppy belts with whales on them at one time in the 80s. But besides that, nothing else. He said the real Andy would never punch his fist through a wall. However, Greg said the real-life Jim Houtpert is very sociable, athletic, and romantic. Oh!
Greg said he was at his wedding and his marriage was beautiful and his wife is completely pan-worthy. He has many of the qualities that he wanted the character of Jim to have as well. Greg said when he met John Krasinski, he reminded him of the real-life Jim helper. Greg said they're both incredibly admirable men. Greg said that in real life, Andy Bernhardt is a renowned economist who studies globalization and was named by Reuters as one of the world's most influential scientific minds. Oh my goodness!
The real-life Jim Halpert works in the White House as general counsel to the National Cyber Director trying to write laws to protect people's security and privacy on the internet. Okay Greg's friends are really smart. He said this is why I asked them both if it was okay to share a recent photo of the three of us. Oh. And Greg said we can put it in the office lady's pod. Story of stories. Oh great. Yes. And it's the cutest picture. And I'm just imagining these three guys are way back together. First grade.
Yeah. There's probably not a photo of that because we just didn't have cameras like we do now, but I love this friendship. What a lifelong friendship. Yeah. I love that. Thank you, Greg.
Thank you, Greg, and thank you, Curtis. Yes. And for all of you, Greg Daniels fans out there, you know, season three of Upload is now streaming on Amazon Prime Video. The trailer is awesome. We have to put that in our stories, Angela. And by the way, if you have not watched Upload, it is so good. It has like 93% on Rotten Tomatoes.
You should definitely check it out. Well, that's all I have for FastFacts, ladies. It has like 93% on Rotten Tomatoes. You should definitely check it out. Well, that's all I have for Fast Facts, lady. Should we get into our last breakdown of an episode from season eight? Let's do it because we have a little bit of old tech that was new tech at the time. Oh, well, we'll take a break and discuss. We are back and Oscar is talking directly to a camera on his computer. He's doing like one of those like a webcam, like, you know, like one of those
professionals that folks do on YouTube. Now, you guys, people were not doing this yet. This was the very beginning. So this whole scene and the way the camera was set up and how Oscars talking directly to the internet as I call it. Yes. That wasn't really happening and it wasn't featured very much on television.
So this was a little bit of like, you know, new technology. And of course, now we look at it and we're like, oh my gosh. Yeah, people do it all the time. All the time. Well, I asked Steve Burgess, how do we get this shot? And he said, Matt Sone just set up one of the cameras on Oscar's desk, moved the computer out of the way and set the camera there with this sort of special lens. And then everybody just walked over and talked into it as if it was a webcam.
It's very funny, you know, Dwight and Phyllis are kind of lurking behind. Kelly comes in and touches up her makeup, Robert then comes in and just starts talking straight to camera, takes over, headbutts, Kevin, and then it all falls apart. Yeah. So Oscar ultimately tells the youth, you know what, it may not get much better,
but it does get a little better. Okay. Well, this episode opens with a Dwight talking head. And he's explaining that he wanted to give the tenants of the building something nice. So he has set up a family portrait studio in the break room. And during this talking head, we are seeing groups of people getting their picture taken. Yes. I will say for this montage, everyone that's getting their picture taken. Yes. I will say for this montage,
everyone that's getting their picture taken, there was written dialogue. There was. Yes, that wasn't used. Please tell me more. Well, Toby and his daughter are doing a dance and she's like saying, Jazz hands dad and he can't quite get it.
Stanley and his daughter just have a sweet moment, you know? And then Creed and his parents, he's like, look, I'm in a parent sandwich, you know, Creed is just being cuckoo pants. And then Meredith and her son just continue to yell at each other. I see. Yeah. So there was just extra beats of all of it. Well, if you're wondering who played all the family members, Toby's daughter was played by Delaney Ruth Farrell. She was the daughter of our set dresser. Stanley's daughter was played by Sarah Rebecca. Cree's parents were played by Ed Ford Jr. and Jackie Beno
and Meredith Sun was played again by Spencer Daniels. Shout out to our actual NBC set photographer and Kate Flanery's longtime fellow, Chris Hastings, for working the Dwight's Family Portrait studio. You'll see him in the corner. He's sitting at the desk, kind of logging all the pictures onto the computer. I saw him.
I also want to share with you guys in the shooting draft, there would have been an establishing shot of the flyer for this free family portrait studio, and here's what it said. Oh, boy. In all caps on the flyer, it says, free family portrait studio, all professional exclamation point, May 9th, noon to 5 p.m.
in Dunderclund Breakroom, courtesy of building manager Dwight K. Shrewt. All professional. Please guys, keep it professional. And I have another tidbit to add about this scene. You thought I was done. I've got one too. It's the scene that keeps on giving.
Okay. Here's mine. In the shooting draft, the person who was in the very front of the line who would have been first up to get their picture taken was, any guesses? Oh, this is a good question. Um, Kevin? No. It was Brandon. And this might explain a little bit of that photo at the end. Oh! Here's how it read and it's also in deleted scenes. Interior break room.
Brandon and Val are at the front of the line. Photographer, next up, Brandon checks himself in a compact mirror and steps up. Val follows. Brandon waves her off and says, baby, I need some singles, okay? She says, what? And he goes, I need some singles and he shoes her away.
And then he turns to the photographer and he says, can we clear some of this kid stuff out of here? This is a promotional shot for my restaurant and I am selling three things, food, sex, and laughter. And then he does a series of photos with that kind of in mind. And Val is just sitting on the side just watching him like, what the hell? He didn't want to picture with his own girlfriend. I have a question.
Is Val wearing her warehouse uniform in the scene? Yes. Why? She wants a portrait with her boyfriend and she's in her like work uniform and he's in regular clothes. This is very poor planning. Well, it bothered me later too. We can talk about it more. Yes, it doesn't really look like most everyone dressed for this photo. Pam really dressed her kids for this photo. Pam went all out. As did Angela or the Senator.
The Senator. Angela had nothing to do with it. But I wanted to share this scene because it just shows you the dynamic of their relationship. He didn't even want to picture with her. He wanted photos by himself. That doesn't feel good. I wish we had that scene in. I just want more of Jerry Minor. Oh, he's very funny in it.
He went so good in that. His poses are hilarious. We got a fan catch from Emily J. In Ohio who said, Creed brings in his parents for a photo, but in season six, the cover-up, Creed says his mom has died. You know what, Emily, you can't trust anything Creed says. These might not be his parents. I was going to say he might have multiple families in different places.
Yeah. I think that is a good catch, at the same time anything goes with Crater. Yeah, which I think the writers took to heart. I think his show Bible is a bit squirrely. It's all over the place. It's just a bunch of contradictions. Yeah, but very good catch. Mm-hmm. Dwight now enters the bullpen and announces there's only a few more hours left of the portrait studio.
He suggests for Daryl to bring his daughter in, for Angela to bring Philip. Right now, enters the bullpen and announces there's only a few more hours left of the portrait studio. He suggests for Darrell to bring his daughter in, for Angela to bring Philip, maybe Jim could bring his two cuties. And Jim says, you know what, I know why Dwight's doing this. Yes. He has a whole talking head where he describes that he did this elaborate prank where he got Dwight's suits and made them with Terroway Velcro. What is Jim's budget for these pranks?
Have you ever had alterations done? I'm a short person. I have to get everything altered. And it is not cheap. Well, you know, Angela, in our fan appreciation mailbag episode, we discussed this scene. We did. I read a letter from Jovi and Oregon,
and he had done an in-depth breakdown of what it costs Jim to prank Dwight over all of these many years. If you haven't listened to that episode and you're interested in really digging deep into this subject, you can go back and listen to it. Jovi from Oregon, he thinks that this Teriway suit was Jim's second most expensive prank and he broke down the cost like this. He had to buy an alternate cheap suit that cost about $200. He had to have a tailor sew velcro into it. He estimates
that was $100. Easily $100. Easily. And he included a tip for the dry cleaner that was $10. So he estimates this prank costs $310. Yeah. I mean, how does Pam feel about that? I mean, is their family so flush with finances that they can afford to spend $310 on this print? Absolutely not. No one, no one wants to spend $300 on a tarot way suit. Like, what are you doing? Yeah. I will say this, what?
Maybe we'll get mail about it, but I'm just gonna say it. What is it? I think Jim's pranks are Roy's jet skis. Mm. Oh boy. Uh-huh. Because that is a strong statement.
It's a strong statement, but if you add up everything Jim spends on pranks, what could that be a vacation for their family? Could they go to Disneyland? Could they maybe splurge and buy that new sofa they've been wanting? No, they bought a tarot way suit. Ooh, Angela.
Oh boy. I had not ever thought of it. Here's my yes and to that theory. Do you think Jim checked in with Pam before doing this? Did he say, hey, baby, I have a hilarious idea. What if I do a tear away suit? And then did she say, how much is that going to cost? And he said, I don't know, maybe 300, 310.
But remember, she said that's hilarious. We should do it. Do you think he consulted her? He bought a whole house without talking to her. Well, now we're going there. Well, I'm just saying, people come for Pam all the time, but we don't discuss exactly what you said, which is that there's no trips to Disneyland
because we're pranking our coworker and not talking to our wife about it first. Yes. Yeah. We're on to something here. I think that there is a pattern of Jim spending the couple's money without consulting Pam. We're going to see it coming up again. I think these pranks are the jet skis.
That was Roy spending the couple's money without Pam's consent. Why does Pam pick men who spend her money without talking to her first? Pam gets some therapy. Well, Jim is going to finish this talking head by saying he now thinks that Dwight is trying to get payback on him for this prank. Yes. And once Jim to bring his kids to work, and this is making him feel very nervous. Yeah. Immediately after Jim's talking head, there was a Dwight talking head. They filmed a few versions of this talking head. None of them made it into the episode. This one was my favorite.
It was a quote must shoot, okay? Right? So we filmed it, but it didn't make it in. Dwight would have said, this is nothing to do with Jim. I'm merely trying to determine whether Angela's son is mine. Of course, if he is, I will raise him to be Jim's enemy. It involves Jim in that sense. Oh, I love that. Next up is a scene that I absolutely loved. Darryl is going to be talking with Heade and Glenn. They lost all of their lottery
winnings already. Heade blames the bad economy, bad investments. It has my favorite line in the episode. Is it Calvin's line? No, it's Darrell's line. Okay, there's so many good lines in here. Okay. But Darrell says so nobody wanted an energy drink for Asian homosexuals.
And then Calvin says they did not. I love the delivery so much. They did not. Okay, my favorite line was when Darryl, you know, he's going to try the drink. Yes. And he's like, what's the flavor? And they take coconut peanuts. And then Darryl takes a sip and goes, the coconut's pretty subtle. That's pretty amazing. Oh, so well written. So we got a lot of fan mail about this scene, right or end from Idaho said, what is the writing on the can of the energy drink?
Doesn't mean anything in particular. And Anna O from Tokyo, Japan, wrote in to answer that very question. Oh great. Tell us what it actually says. Anna said, as an office fan from Japan, I was thrilled to see He-Day in the cold open of this episode. And when he handed Darryl the Japanese energy drink, I had to pause and read what it said on the can.
To directly translate, it says, gay energy superpower flavor. Banished lazy attitudes to the land of wind and ghosts. Okay, thank you so much. I had no idea what it actually said all these years. And you know what? I looked in the script to see if there was any description of the can or what was written on the can. No. So Phil Shea had to invent this all himself. It's so well done. We also got a fan catch from Adrian G and Connecticut who said continuity error when the two former warehouse workers and Andy come into the office this week. None of them are wearing the visitor pass that Aaron
直接翻译过来的话，意思是，基情满满的能量超级大国风味。把懒散的态度流放到风鬼之乡。好吧，非常感谢。这么多年来我一直不知道它到底写的是什么。你知道吗？我查了剧本，看看有没有关于这个罐子或罐子上写了什么的描述。没有。所以菲尔·谢伊（Phil Shea）不得不完全靠自己编造这个。做得太好了。我们还收到了来自康涅狄格州的阿德里安·G（Adrian G）的粉丝捉虫，他说本周那两个前仓库工人和安迪走进办公室时出现了连贯性错误。他们都没有戴阿龙在
established in episode 23. Oh, none of them the whole day. People, family members are coming in and out. There's no visitor passes. No visitor passes. We also got a really nice note about Hide. This is from Shuhei in Tokyo, but who's currently living in Australia. Shuhei said, after I had listened to the podcast episode for Body Language where you shared that Hide was on Instagram, I sent him a direct message in Japanese letting him know that I'm a big fan of his character. He surprisingly
第23集中设定的访客证。哦，整整一天都没有一个人戴。人们、家属进进出出。根本没有访客证。没有访客证。我们还收到了一封关于希德（Hide）的非常好的留言。这是来自东京的修平（Shuhei）发的，但他目前住在澳大利亚。修平说，在听了播客“肢体语言”那一集、听到你们分享希德在Instagram上之后，我用日语给他发了一条私信，告诉他我是他角色的超级粉丝。他居然
replied back to me thanking me in a very polite way, but this wasn't the end. He offered his autograph and actually sent it all the way to Sydney, Australia. The whole interaction I had with him and Hiday as a person were literally the best. I mean, this doesn't surprise me. Not at all. He's a lovely person. This is who he is. Yeah, he's so warm and gracious. I'd like to mention that if you love Hiday
非常礼貌地回复我并向我道谢，但这还没完。他主动提出给我签名，并且真的把签名寄到了澳大利亚悉尼。我和他之间的整个互动，以及希德这个人本身，简直棒极了。我的意思是，这并不让我意外。一点也不意外。他是个可爱的人。他本来就是这样的人。是的，他非常热情亲切。我想提一下，如果你喜欢希德
and would like a personalized message from him, he's on cameo. That's the website where you can request videos from celebrities. So if maybe I don't know, you're looking for a last minuteminute holiday gift for someone, maybe ask today to make a video. I'll put it in stories so you can find it. Well, this scene is going to end because Darryl sees Val walking into the office and he gets up. He's like, hold up,
并且想要一张他个性化的祝福视频，他在Cameo上。这是一个你可以向名人请求定制视频的网站。所以也许，我不知道，如果你在为主某人寻找一份最后一分钟的节日礼物，也许可以请希德拍个视频。我会把它发在快拍里，这样你们就能找到了。好了，这个场景要结束了，因为达里尔（Darryl）看到瓦尔（Val）走进办公室，他就站了起来。他当时想，等等，
one second. Then he sees Brandon. Yeah. And he has a talking head where he says, you know what, if he was Val, he would break up with Brandon and then date the hell out of him. Yeah. Yeah. Well, after this talking head, there would have started, Jenna. The most bonkers, Jim Pam, Robert, California storyline. I remember it. Oh, it was a whole runner. It was so weird. It goes throughout the entire episode. You can also watch it all play out and deleted scenes on the DVD. But I wanted to play it for you all. Oh, boy.
等一下。然后他看到了布兰登（Brandon）。是的。他有一个单人访谈，在访谈中他说，你知道吗，如果他是瓦尔，他就会跟布兰登分手，然后狠狠地追求他。是的。是的。好吧，在这个单人访谈之后，本来应该开始，珍娜。最疯狂的、吉姆、帕姆、罗伯特·加利福尼亚的剧情线。我记得。哦，这是一个连续的支线。太诡异了。它贯穿了整集。你也可以在DVD的删除片段中观看所有这些剧情的展开。但我很想放给你们大家听。哦，天哪。
Yeah, I need you to hear it. And thanks to Cassie, who helped me stitch these moments together so we can play it all as one. I'm going to give you a hint to the subject matter. It's just the number three. Oh, boy. Uh-huh. Shared silence. The hallmark of an authentic relationship.
是的，我需要你们听听。多亏了卡西（Cassie）帮我把这些片段拼接在一起，我们才能把它们连成一段播放。我要给你们一个关于主题的提示。它只有一个数字：三。哦，天哪。嗯哼。共享的沉默。真实关系的标志。
Your intimacy. And nobles this office. Thank you. Robert, that is a really sweet thing to say. I want to be part of it. Huh? Okay. Great. It's from Robert. Saturday 10, question mark. Yeah, I could hear you do the question mark.
你们的亲密感。成全了这个办公室。谢谢你。罗伯特，这话真暖心。我想成为其中的一部分。啊？好吧。太棒了。这是罗伯特发来的。星期六10点，问号。是的，我能听出你打问号时的语气。
Tens a little late for dinner. We were just wondering what we could bring on Saturday. Oh, no, no, nothing. I have everything we'll need. Do you have any new categories? Yeah. Yes. We love categories.
10点吃晚饭有点太晚了。我们只是想知道星期六能带点什么。哦，不，不，不用。我需要的东西都有。你们有什么新分类吗？对。有。我们喜欢分类。
That's great. Yeah. We'll need the icosahedron dye from it. 20 sides. Just enough. Huh? Great. Well, we're looking forward to it.
那太好了。对。我们需要里面那个二十面骰子。20个面。刚刚好。啊？太好了，那我们很期待。
Me three. Me three. Yeah. This is crazy. We're being crazy. Totally. Yeah. So where should you go? Yes. You know we can't go. No, we should stay home, sorry, and I... I can make my salmon. This is gonna haunt us, yes. Yep. God, what a couple. Jim and Pam, given the circumstances, I'm afraid I must cancel our Saturday night. Oh, yeah, of course. I'm sorry.
我也是三个。我也是三个。是的。这太疯狂了。我们简直疯了。完全是。是的。那你们该去哪儿？对。你知道我们不能去。不，我们应该呆家里，抱歉，而且我……我可以做我的三文鱼。这会缠着我们不放的，是的。没错。天哪，多么般配的一对。吉姆和帕姆，鉴于目前的情况，恐怕我必须取消我们周六晚上的聚会了。哦，对，当然。我很抱歉。
Me too. Just out of curiosity. What would we have been doing? Exactly. Three way. I hate's okay. Lady. Yep. Robert, California wanted to have a threesome with Jim and Pam. Yeah. They're like, this is what it is, but is it? They're doubting themselves, but they know. I had completely forgotten about this. If you would have asked me this on an office trivia night, I had 100% say no.
我也是。出于好奇。我们本来要做什么来着？没错。3P。海蒂还好。女神。没错。罗伯特·加利福尼亚想和吉姆和帕姆玩3P。是的。他们当时觉得，事情就是这样，但真的是这样吗？他们对自己产生了怀疑，但他们心里其实很清楚。我完全把这事忘得精光。如果你在办公室知识问答之夜问我这个，我100%会说没有。
There was never a storyline where Robert wanted a threesome with Jim and Pam. But there was. Yeah. That's crazy. Crazy. Well, Jenna, we have a fan question about it. We do. Yes, we do.
根本没有罗伯特想和吉姆和帕姆玩3P的剧情线。但确实有。是的。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。好吧，珍娜，我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问。确实有。是的，确实有。
You're dipping into the fan questions over there, you know. I am L.A.E. from the UK wrote in and said, I want to know Jenna, how did you and John react to this storyline? How did you guys get through the scene where Robert says otherwise, I wanna know, Jenna, how did you and John react to this storyline? How did you guys get through the scene where Robert says otherwise, I'm just a guy, f***ing two parents. Ella, it was very hard to keep a straight face during all of this.
你在那边偷看粉丝提问呢，你知道的。来自英国的L.A.E.写信说，我想知道，珍娜，你和约翰对这个剧情线有什么反应？你们俩是怎么拍完罗伯特说“不然的话，我只想知道，珍娜，你和约翰对这个剧情线有什么反应？你们俩是怎么拍完罗伯特说‘不然的话，我只是个跟两个当父母的乱搞的家伙’”这场戏的？埃拉，在拍所有这些的时候要保持严肃真的太难了。
That was a doozy, but it was especially difficult for me in the scenes that were just Jim and Pam because John is particularly funny to me. He's so funny. When he's in denial. And when he's in denial are her little like freak daughter scared. Yes.
那真是一个奇葩的桥段，但对我来说，尤其是在只有吉姆和帕姆的场景中特别难熬，因为约翰对我来说格外搞笑。他太搞笑了。当他处于否认状态时。当他处于否认状态时，她那种像受到惊吓的小女儿般的反应。是的。
Yes. In fact, John in this whole episode is some of my favorite John Krizensky comedy. You know, when he's taking the picture, when he's like worried something's gonna come get him, it reminds me of, you know, when he's walking out among all of the snowmen. Yes, yes, that's just some of my favorite John Comedy. So I am glad we cut this storyline. I think it was too much, but I did enjoy shooting it.
是的。事实上，约翰在这一整集里的表现堪称我最喜欢的约翰·卡拉辛斯基喜剧表演。你知道的，当他在拍照时，当他担心有什么东西要来抓他时，这让我想起，你知道的，他在雪人群中走来走去的时候。是的，是的，那绝对是我最喜欢的约翰喜剧桥段。所以我很高兴我们剪掉了这条剧情线。我觉得有点过火了，但我真的很享受拍摄过程。
I made these laugh. I laughed really hard when they're trying to get to the bottom of like, what are we doing at 10 p.m.? Like what is happening? We're not eating and you guys go in the conference room and the part that really made me laugh is when Robert says, do you like scatigories? The two of you have such a moment of relief.
我笑了。当他们试图弄清楚10点钟到底在干什么、到底发生了什么时，我笑得超大声。比如我们不吃东西，然后你们俩走进会议室，真正让我大笑的桥段是罗伯特说：“你们喜欢快智迷宫（Scattergories）吗？”你们俩脸上露出了那种如释重负的表情。
Like, yes, we love scatigories. But then it quickly turns and you're like, oh, I love the reveal that Jim has a salmon that he makes. I know. Should I make my salmon? I'll make my salmon. Let's just forget it ever happened. Lady, I think we should take a break. I think I need a moment. Oh, after that? Yeah. All right. Well, I think we do need a big reset and I think I have the perfect thing. Oh, really, Angela? I do as head of the party planning committee. It is happy holidays here at Office Ladies.
就像，是的，我们超级喜欢快智迷宫。但紧接着情况急转直下，你们俩心想，哦，我太喜欢吉姆会做一道三文鱼的设定了。我知道。我要不要做我的三文鱼？我来做三文鱼吧。让我们忘了这事发生过吧。女神，我觉得我们该休息一下了。我觉得我需要缓一缓。哦，经历了那个之后？好吧。好吧，我觉得我们的确需要一次大重置，我想我正好有完美的东西。哦，真的吗，安吉拉？作为派对策划委员会的主席，我有的。这里是办公室辣妹的快乐假日。
Sam and Cassie get ready to open some presents because we are doing our gift exchange today. That's right, and we have sweet treats. You guys, this is my favorite time. I know, Kinsy Claus is here. Kinsy Claus! You know we're about to go on our two-week holiday break. And before we do, we had to give you some gifts, Sam.
萨姆和卡西，准备好拆礼物吧，因为我们今天要进行礼物交换。没错了，而且我们还有甜点。各位，这是我最喜欢的时刻。我知道，金茜圣诞老人（Kinsy Claus）来啦。金茜圣诞老人！你们知道我们马上就要开始为期两周的假期了。在此之前，我们必须送你一些礼物，萨姆。
We wrapped yours in our own faces. In our faces? We thought you would appreciate it. Cassie, I wrapped yours in the Unicorn Princess paper. Here you are, Sam. It is the green day when we were young festival t-shirt. We both went to this concert! Yes!
我们用印着我们自己脸的包装纸把你的礼物包了起来。印着我们的脸？我们觉得你会喜欢的。卡西，我用独角兽公主的纸帮你包了礼物。给你，萨姆。这是绿色日乐队“当我们年轻时”音乐节的T恤。我们俩都去过这个演唱会！是的！
I love it. Thank you. You're welcome. Yeah, this is great. Yeah. Cassie, I just saw these and I thought of you and I just think they're so cute. Angela sent me multiple photos of these, by the way.
我太喜欢了。谢谢。不客气。是的，这太棒了。是的。卡西，我一看到这些就想到了你，我觉得它们实在太可爱了。顺便说一句，安吉拉给我发了好几张这些东西的照片。
Yes! They're little silver kitty cat earrings. And each kitty's in a different pose. Yes. So cute, I love it. That's so cute. And then Josh made ginger cookies with candy cane herchee kisses in the middle.
对！它们是小银猫耳耳环。而且每只猫咪的姿势都不一样。对。太可爱了，我好喜欢。太可爱了。然后乔什做了生姜饼干，中间放了好时好时之吻（Hersey Kisses）糖果。
I love the candy cane herchee kiss. They're my favorite. And Jenna, you are not forgotten. Here's some gluten-free shirtbread cookies. gluten free shirtbread cookies. And I brought extra things so everyone can take cookies home. Yeah! Happy holidays! Happy holidays! Oh wait you guys I have one more thing. You know for years on the office Jenna would make us all Christmas ornaments. And then when we started office ladies I made us Christmas ornaments and then I kind of dropped the ball on it. So I made us all Christmas ornaments. And then when we started office ladies, I made us Christmas ornaments, and then I kind of dropped the ball on it. So I made us all a Christmas ornament this year.
我超爱糖果好时之吻。它们是我的最爱。还有珍娜，你没有被忘掉。这里有些无麸质酥饼曲奇。无麸质酥饼曲奇。我还多带了一些东西，这样大家都可以带饼干回家。耶！节日快乐！节日快乐！哦等等，你们大家，我还有最后一件事。你知道，多年来在《办公室》剧组，珍娜都会为我们所有人制作圣诞饰品。然后当我们开始做《办公室辣妹》播客时，我给我们制作了圣诞饰品，接着我在这方面有点懈怠了。所以，我给我们制作了圣诞饰品。然后当我们开始做《办公室辣妹》播客时，我给我们制作了圣诞饰品，接着我在这方面有点懈怠了。所以，今年我为我们所有人制作了一个圣诞饰品。
Hey! Okay, there you go. Now, you turn it on the other side. Turn the other side. Yeah. What is it? It's a picture of the four of us. It's a wooden cube,
嘿！好了，给你。现在，你把它翻到另一面。翻到另一面。对。这是什么？这是我们四个人的照片。这是一个木质方块，
and then on the other side, there's a perigranny panties that say, getting sh** done. I love it. This is perfect. This is amazing. Well, that is the pellet cleansing that I needed, Angela. Thank you. Thank you. Let's go to break it when we come back. And he's got a real unique outfit on. Yeah.
然后另一面，印着一双老奶奶内裤，上面写着：搞定工作（getting sh** done）。我太喜欢了。这太完美了。这太棒了。好吧，这正是我需要的净心剂，安吉拉。谢谢你。谢谢。我们去休息一下，回来继续。他穿了一套真的很独特的衣服。是的。
These cookies are so good. Josh crushed it. Josh these cookies are really good. Even though I've moved from no gluten to avoiding gluten and I'm not going to avoid these cookies. She told me right away. She was like, I will be having one of those. All right, listen, while we were on break and we're eating our cookies, we started talking to Sam about his new podcast that's coming out. Sam, will you tell everyone about it? Because I'm so excited. We are so excited about this, Sam.
这些饼干太好吃了。乔什太牛了。乔什，这些饼干真的很好吃。尽管我已经从不吃麸质转变为尽量避免麸质，但我不会错过这些饼干的。她马上就告诉我了。她当时说，我一定要吃一个。好了，听着，在我们休息吃饼干的时候，我们开始和萨姆聊起他即将推出的新播客。萨姆，你能不能跟每个人介绍一下？因为我太兴奋了。我们对这个超级兴奋，萨姆。
Enemy in Paris. Sure, sorry, I'm also eating. Also, the title is Perfect Sam. Yeah, it's a hate watch along podcast for Emily in Paris. I received feedback from my comments on the show. Other people dislike the show. So myself and a comedian named Beck Hill are going through and watching the show from the start and tearing it apart. Brilliant. Oh my gosh. Can I please come on an episode? Please. Sure can. Both of you can. Same. I absolutely love Emily and Paris
巴黎的敌人。当然，抱歉，我还在吃。还有，这个名字太完美了，萨姆。是的，这是一个针对《艾米丽在巴黎》的“边看边骂”播客。我收到了大家对我评价这部剧的反馈。其他人也很讨厌这部剧。所以我和一个名叫贝克·希尔（Beck Hill）的喜剧演员决定一起从头观看这部剧，然后把它批得体无完肤。太棒了。噢天哪。我能去当一期嘉宾吗？求你了。当然可以。你们两个都可以。萨姆。我绝对超爱《艾米丽在巴黎》
and also hate it all at the same time. Yes, I can't get enough of it. I have so many feelings about it. Yes, this podcast was needed and I'm so excited. And when does it start? I comes out December 20th. Okay, so perfect. For the holidays, are you kidding?
但也同时恨透了它。对，我对它爱不释手。我对它有太多的感受了。是的，这个播客太需要了，我太兴奋了。它什么时候开播？12月20日上线。好吧，太完美了。作为节日礼物，你开玩笑呢吧？
Yeah, one of my favorite things to Sam is when you were in Paris, how you went to places. Oh yeah, we stopped by Emily's apartment, we stopped by Gabriel's restaurant, and got filled with anger. And then you have like snarky content. Mm-hmm. Snarky photos.
对，萨姆，我最喜欢的事情之一就是你在巴黎的时候，你是怎么去那些地方的。哦，对，我们顺路去了艾米丽的公寓，去了加布里埃尔的餐厅，然后充满了愤怒。然后你还发布了一些讽刺的内容。嗯哼。讽刺的照片。
All right, we should get back to this episode. Mm-hmm, Andy. He has shown up to work in a, I guess like a boiler suit. Yeah, he hasn't shaved shaved his hair is all a mess He tells Jim he's fine. He goes into Nellie's office and asks if there's any work he could do He can pull the poop out of the toilets if she needs you know on this day where Andy most definitely doesn't look fine Even though he's orchestrating this whole look. Mm-hmm. You would think they would want him to log in and get his visitor label. Listen, they were worried when he was sitting outside
好了，我们该回到这一集了。嗯哼，安迪。他穿着一身，我猜像是工装连裤服来上班。是的，他没有刮胡子，头发乱蓬蓬的。他告诉吉姆他很好，然后走进奈莉的办公室，问有没有什么工作需要他做。如果她需要的话，他甚至可以去厕所掏大粪。你知道的，在安迪绝对看起来一点都不好的这一天里，尽管这一切造型都是他精心策划的。嗯哼。你会觉得他们至少会想让他去打卡领个访客证。听着，当他坐在外面
in his car, but I feel more worried now. Yes. When we talk about clunky moments in season eight, I'm sorry, but this one was hard for me. It's very hard for me when he is mopping the floor, the carpet. The carpet with like a bucket of water. What?
车里时他们就很担心，但我现在更担心了。是的。当我们谈到第八季里那些生硬尴尬的时刻时，对不起，但这个对我来说真的很难。当他在拖地、擦地毯时，我真的很难受。用一桶水擦地毯？什么鬼？
He has a talking head where he explains that he has a delicious secret. This is all fake because at three o'clock today, David Wallace is gonna walk into the office. He's gonna announce that he has purchased under Mifflin and he is reinstating Andy as manager. I would say this is a cautionary tale for anyone out there that feels like they need to have a moment of like,
他有一个单人访谈，在访谈中他解释说他有一个美妙的秘密。这一切都是假的，因为今天下午三点，大卫·华莱士（David Wallace）将走进办公室。他将宣布他收购了邓德米夫林，并恢复安迪经理的职务。我要说的是，这对任何觉得自己需要来一个“捉弄”、“复仇”时刻的人来说，都是一个警世故事。
gacha, like revenge moment, gacha. Yeah. It's never gonna play out the way you hope. Also, it is sort of the poison that poisons the well. Mm-hmm. No, how's that saying go? I'm proud of my name. I mean, I'm sure it's not it's the poison that poisons the well. No, how's that saying go? I'm proud of it. I mean, I'm sure it's not it's the poison that poisons the well. No, no, no, no, it's it's the poison that poisons the bottle that holds it.
这绝对不会按你希望的那样发展。而且，这某种程度上就是“污染水源”的毒药。嗯哼。不对，那句俗语怎么说来着？我为我的名字感到骄傲。我的意思是，我确信那不是——是“污染水源的毒药”。不对，那句话怎么说来着？我挺骄傲的。我的意思是，我确信那不是——是“污染水源的毒药”。不不不不，那是——那是“污染盛酒瓶的毒药”。
Anyway, I don't know, but I'm just saying is that a saying it's the poison that poisons the bottle that holds it. I just made it up maybe. Is it I feel like what are you going for? It's the it up maybe. Is it, I feel like, what are you going for? It's the, it's the, it's the, it's the, it's the, it's the well. No, I'm going for it. Poisons the bottle that holds it. So here you are. You have just taken into your body this resentment, this revenge.
总之，我不知道，但我只是在想，这算是一句俗语吗？是“污染盛酒瓶的毒药”。也许是我刚编的。是吗？我觉得——你到底想表达什么？是——是——是——是——是水源。不，我要说的是：污染了盛酒瓶的毒药。所以，瞧。你刚刚把这种怨恨、这种复仇吸收到你的身体里。
I mean, I show them, right, that energy. And the more you pull, and my body is the bottle. Yes. And the more you hold all that in body is the bottle. Yes. And the more you hold all that in, it poisons you. It poisons the bottle that holds it. Thank you. I'm liking this phrase. If this isn't a phrase, I like it.
我的意思是，我让他们好看，对吧，那种能量。你越是压抑，我的身体就是那个瓶子。是的。你把所有这些压在心里，它就会毒害你。它污染了盛酒瓶的毒药。谢谢你。我很喜欢这个短语。如果这不是一句现成的俗语，我也很喜欢它。
Don't poison the bottle that holds it. Don't poison the bottle that holds it. I like it. You just put on your glasses with emphasis and looked at me over the top of them after you said it. You just put on your glasses with emphasis and looked at me over the top of them after you said it. I think that means you're onto a good saying. Okay. Well, Pam is now gonna arrive with C.C. and Philip.
别污染了盛酒瓶的毒药。别污染了盛酒瓶的毒药。我喜欢。你刚才说完之后，意味深长地戴上眼镜，从镜框上方看了我一眼。你刚才说完之后，意味深长地戴上眼镜，从镜框上方看了我一眼。我想这说明你想出了一句好名言。好吧。好吧，现在帕姆带着西西（CC）和菲利普（Philip）到了。
It's family picture time. Jim is like, whoa, whoa, whoa, what, what are you doing here? This is where I love paranoid Jim. You're loving. They go into pose for photos and Jim could not look more freaked out in every picture. What are they doing with those pictures? I can't be in the Christmas card.
全家福拍照时间到。吉姆整个人：哦，等等，等等，等等，你在干什么？这就是我喜欢偏执狂吉姆的地方。你很喜欢。他们摆好姿势拍照，吉姆在每一张照片里的表情看起来都惊恐万分。他们拿着那些照片在干什么？我可不能出现在圣诞贺卡里。
I improvise the line. Okay, so I'll just stand here when he takes like both children. The kids, yeah. Also, I want to say that they brought these kids to set. I had no idea what they were going to be wearing. The little purple bows and Cece's hair that kind of matched what Pam was wearing. It was all so coordinated. I was like, this is what I can never do in my real life.
我即兴发挥了一句台词。好吧，那他就拿两个孩子好了，我就站在这儿。孩子们，对。另外，我想说他们把这些孩子带到了片场。我完全不知道他们会穿什么衣服。西西头发上的小紫蝴蝶结跟帕姆穿的衣服挺搭的。这一切都搭配得天衣无缝。当时我就想，这是我在现实生活中绝对做不到的事。
No. I can never coordinate all our outfits. We will never send you a family holiday card where we are coordinated. I tried one time. One time. I didn't go. We were at Josh's sister's wedding in Hawaii, and I thought, Christmas card opportunity here.
不。我绝不可能把我们所有的服装都搭配好。我们绝不会给你寄一张全家福节日贺卡，上面每个人的衣服都是搭配好的。我尝试过一次。就一次。我没去。我们在乔什在夏威夷的姐姐的婚礼上，我想，这是拍圣诞贺卡的好机会啊。
I never did this now, I'm sorry to laugh. Why? I didn't. And I wanted us all to have like a shirt that looked tropical, like sailboats or you know flowers or you know someone surfing or coral fish. Yeah, it was such a thing. No one wanted to wear their shirts.
我真不该这么干的，不好意思我笑场了。为什么？我没这么干。我本来想让我们所有人都穿一件看起来很热带风情的衬衫，比如上面有帆船、花朵，或者有人在冲浪，或者有珊瑚鱼那种。是的，当时就是这样。结果没人愿意穿那些衬衫。
I know I remember. But you did get a very nice picture and you were all dressed up. You just weren't in coordinating outfits. Well, we couldn't. No one wanted to wear the same thing. But you know, then ultimately I just went for, okay, tropical, whatever that means to you. Well, Angela, I think your card turned out adorable.
我知道，我记得。但你们确实拍了一张非常好看的照片，而且你们都盛装打扮了。只是衣服没有刻意搭配而已。好吧，我们没办法。没人愿意穿一样的。但你知道，最后我还是妥协了，好吧，就热带风情吧，不管这代表什么意思。好吧，安吉拉，我觉得你们的贺卡拍得可爱极了。
Thank you. And Jim and Pam's color coordination in this family photo, I was like, wow, they did it. They did it, they look great. I have a bunch of fan questions I can get to. Rider N from Idaho said, was there a fake baby used during the filming of this episode, specifically when Pam brings her kids into the office?
谢谢。还有吉姆和帕姆在这张全家福里的颜色搭配，当时我就想，哇，他们做到了。他们做到了，看起来太棒了。我手头有一堆粉丝提问可以回答。来自爱达荷州的莱德·N（Ryder N）说，在拍摄这一集时，特别是当帕姆把孩子带到办公室时，是不是用了一个假婴儿？
Nope, Ryder? There were not. We had a real baby, Phillip Helpert, who was played by some twin girls in this episode, Mahina and Malia Hatchee. And at six minutes and 12 seconds, I don't know which one of them is in the stroller, but there is a baby in that stroller. And you can see the baby's legs kicking as I push it toward the break room. And I actually really appreciated that
没有，莱德？并没有。我们用的是一个真实的婴儿，小菲利普·霍尔珀特（Philip Halpert），在这集里由一对双胞胎女孩扮演，玛希娜（Mahina）和玛丽亚·哈奇（Malia Hatchee）。在6分12秒时，我不知道其中哪一个在婴儿车里，但那辆婴儿车里的确是一个真婴儿。当我把它推向休息室时，你可以看到婴儿的腿在踢腾。其实我很感激
there was a real baby there. And I was trying to keep it calm. And that's why I keep talking to it during the scene. Yeah. That's why I'm talking to the baby, and it really helped my performance. So I appreciated it. We also had a fan catch from Christopher H and Hawaii who said, did you notice that the duck, the photographer is using to distract the kids when the photos are taken is the same stuffed animal duck
那里有一个真婴儿。我当时正试图保持镇定。这就是为什么我在拍摄过程中一直在跟它说话。是的。这就是为什么我一直在跟婴儿说话，这确实对我的表演很有帮助。所以我很感激。我们还收到了来自夏威夷的克里斯托弗·H（Christopher H）的粉丝捉虫，他说，你有没有注意到，摄影师在拍照时用来吸引孩子们注意力的那只鸭子，就是第三季里托比送给帕姆的那只毛绒玩具鸭？
that Toby gave Pam in season three? No. What a great catch! It's literally exactly the same duck I went back and looked. Speaking of ducks, you guys, you'll remember when we had Claire on, how we talked that she took from set, the quacking duck, not this stuffed animal duck
没有。太厉害的捉虫了！这简直一模一样，我还特意回去看了一下。说到鸭子，大家还记得我们请来克莱尔（Claire）做客时，聊到她从片场顺走了什么吗，是那只嘎嘎叫的鸭子，而不是这个场景里的毛绒玩具鸭，克里斯托弗。
that's in the scene, Christopher. Different duck. The little duck that's sat by the file cabinet by Phyllis's desk. That would go off during takes and rune take after take. Yes. Well, Claire sent this to me the other morning. First thing in the morning, I'm going to read what she said.
不是同一只。是放在菲利斯办公桌旁文件柜旁边的那只小鸭子。它会在拍摄过程中突然叫起来，导致一条又一条的镜头NG。是的。好吧，克莱尔那天早上把这个发给我了。一大早，我来读读她发的内容。
She goes, hey, Angie, good morning from this little guy. And then she took a video of herself hitting the duck. This is the duck, guys, that would rune take after take. This is what it sounded like. I could do it from memory. It has a little tape. It's quite, quite, quite, quite. They say some sounds take you right back to where you were at the moment you can see the famous Quacking Duck. You should. The Senator arrives with Angela's baby, Philip. Angela's like, no, no, no, no, no, what are you doing here? Yes, baby, Philip Lipton.
她说，嘿，安吉，这个小家伙向你问好。然后她拍了一段自己拍打那只鸭子的视频。各位，这就是那只拍戏时会让无数镜头NG的鸭子。声音就是这样的。我凭记忆就能模仿出来。它里面有一小段磁带。就是嘎、嘎、嘎、嘎。人们说有些声音能瞬间把你带回你当时所在的那一刻，你能看到著名的嘎嘎鸭。你应该。参议员带着安吉拉的孩子菲利普来了。安吉拉当时反应：不，不，不，不，不，你来这儿干什么？没错，婴儿菲利普·利普顿（Philip Lipton）。
Also played by twin girls, Ali and Suzy and Hartman. Well, Dwight is gonna welcome Angela and the Senator to the photo studio. Angela will not let Dwight and Hartman go out and get a photo of her. And then, if you're gonna be ableman. Well Dwight is gonna welcome Angela and the Senator to the photo studio. Angela will not let Dwight hold Philip. Dwight keeps trying to get near Philip. Angela has a talking head where she says she thinks
同样由双胞胎女孩艾莉（Ali）和苏茜（Susy）·哈特曼（Hartman）扮演。好吧，德 Dwight 准备欢迎安吉拉和参议员来到照相馆。安吉拉不让德怀特和哈特曼进区给她拍照。然后，如果你要……好吧，德怀特准备欢迎安吉拉和参议员来到照相馆。安吉拉不让德怀特抱菲利普。德怀特一直试图靠近菲利普。安吉拉有一个单人访谈，在访谈中她说她觉得
Dwight's doing this whole thing to get a DNA sample to prove he's the father, which is impossible because the Senator is the only man she's ever been with. I have a question for you. What is it? What's up with my hair? What is up with your hair?
德怀特做这一切是为了获取DNA样本来证明他是孩子的父亲，这根本不可能，因为参议员是她唯一交往过的男人。我有个问题要问你。什么问题？我头发怎么了？你的头发怎么了？
It looks like I had just been in a wind tunnel. What is up with your hair? And then immediately when I go to the family portrait studio, it's totally normal. What happened to my hair? I wondered if there was a deleted scene. Are you so did I? Ripping your hair out in frustration. I odd.
看起来我刚刚去过风洞一样。我的头发怎么了？然后紧接着当我走到全家福照相馆时，它完全正常了。我的头发到底怎么了？我在想是不是有一段被删减的场景。你也在想吗？我也是。气得把头发都扯掉了。我觉得很诡异。
It's very odd. I went to the shooting draft. I went to the candy bag. I watched deleted scenes. I'm not a real baby, if maybe the baby had touched my hair somehow, or I have a little burp cloth, maybe I had tried to put it on the other side and tossed my hair. Yeah, I noticed it as well. Well speaking of messy hair, Dwight wants to try and comb baby Phillips hair,
真的很诡异。我翻了拍摄初稿。我看了糖果袋（幕后花絮）。我看了删减片段。如果这不是真婴儿的话，也许是婴儿不知怎么碰到了我的头发，或者我有一块小溢奶巾，也许我曾试图把它别在另一侧然后把头发甩了过去。对，我也注意到了。好吧，说到凌乱的头发，德怀特想试着给婴儿菲利普梳头，
but Angela swatts him away. These scenes were so fun. They were so funny, Angela. Can we keep going with them? Because Dwight is also going to suggest he trim Phillips toenails. I know. Every time Reign as Dwight came at us and I got to swat him away, I was so fun.
但安吉拉一把把他挥开。这些场景太好玩了。太搞笑了，安吉拉。我们能继续说这些吗？因为德怀特接下来还要建议修剪菲利普的脚趾甲。我知道。每次雷恩（Rainn）饰演的德怀特扑过来，而我不得不把他挥开时，我都觉得太好玩了。
He's going to try to collect excess dry skin. Oh, I know. Could you imagine if like a photographer at a baby studio was like fusing over your baby like this? Also, isn't the senator like, what are you doing Dwight? Like the senator is so checked out. He's so unaware. Oh, you know what? I should give a shout out to Julie Dove who played our fake photographer in all of these scenes. She was very good. Well, little baby Philip Lipton is gonna make the poop skis. Yep. The senator takes them out to change his diaper. Very helpful. Refreshing to see that.
他还想搜集过多的死皮。哦，我懂。你能想象如果婴儿照相馆里的摄影师对你的宝宝这样大惊小怪吗？还有，参议员难道不觉得——你在干什么啊，德怀特？参议员简直神游天外。他完全状况外。哦，你知道吗？我应该向朱莉·多夫（Julie Dove）致敬，她在所有这些场景中扮演了我们的假摄影师。她演得非常好。好吧，小婴儿菲利普·利普顿要拉臭臭了。是的。参议员把他抱出去换尿布。非常乐于助人。看到这一幕真是令人耳目一新。
Dwight is then going to emerge from the bathroom with the diaper. Angela notices this and screams for him and runs after him. Where did Senator Lipton change the diaper in the men's restroom? I don't know because I don't think there's a changing table in there. Well, there's definitely not. I don't think there's a changing table in the women's restroom. Maybe he just laid him down like on the carpet near Kelly's desk. And then he threw it away all the way in the bathroom. I don't know.
接着德怀特手里拿着尿布从洗手间里走了出来。安吉拉注意到了这一幕，尖叫着朝他喊，并追了上去。利普顿参议员是在哪个男厕所里换的尿布？我不知道，因为我觉得那里面根本没有尿布台。好吧，绝对没有。我觉得女厕所里也没有尿布台。也许他只是把他放在凯莉办公桌旁的地毯上。然后他一路把尿布扔到了洗手间。我不知道。
These are logistics I can't get into. There's also something that I noticed because we rarely have this angle where we're in the kitchen like this and we shoot kind of into the bullpen in this way. Yeah. And I noticed that at 10 minutes and 30 seconds, Leslie has a heater under his deck. Oh, I saw that too. And I thought Leslie got cold. I never
这些后勤细节我实在没法深究。还有一件事我注意到了，因为我们很少拍这种我们在厨房里、镜头朝办公区拍摄的角度。对。我注意到在10分30秒时，莱斯利（Leslie）的桌子底下放了一个取暖器。哦，我也看到了。当时我想，莱斯利觉得冷啊。我从来
knew that. I knew we had heaters. I know. I thought only the ladies had heaters. Because the men would wear full suits. Yeah, they know. They were hot. They were warm. But we would have our tights and our skirts and everything. I didn't know this. At least years. I didn't know it either. Learn something new. Well, we should probably go back and discuss Andy.
不知道这个。我知道我们有取暖器。我知道。我以为只有女士们才有取暖器。因为男士们穿的是整套西装。对，他们知道。他们很热。他们很保暖。但我们得穿连裤袜、短裙之类的。我根本不知道这事。这么多年了。我也不知道。活到老学到老。好吧，我们大概应该回去讨论一下安迪了。
We should, because there's a lot going on. He's going to gargle some whiskey. He's going to choke on it. He then brings out soup for Nelly, but then spills it all over himself and then tries to eat it off of his clothes off his arm Aaron's gonna pull Andy aside. She's gonna say hey the payoff for this is gonna be delicious But some of these images are gonna be hard to shake Andy, you know, so calibrate Aaron is having such a
我们确实应该，因为事情太多了。他要漱一口威士忌。他差点被呛到。然后他给奈莉端来了汤，结果把汤洒了自己一身，还试图把自己衣服上、胳膊上的汤舔着吃掉。艾伦把安吉拉到一旁。她说，嘿，这么做的回报绝对会很美味，但其中有些画面你很难忘掉，安吉拉，所以得悠着点。艾伦在这里表现得真是
smart practical sober moment here. Yes, she is, but she also co-signed on Drunken Chimney Sweep. She did. But I appreciate her pumping the brakes on this. Mm-hmm. Meanwhile, Darrell is gonna bring Hiday and Glenn down to the warehouse.
聪明、务实又冷静。是的，她确实如此，但她也默认了“喝醉的烟囱清洁工”这个造型。她确实这么干了。不过我挺欣赏她及时踩刹车的。嗯哼。与此同时，达里尔把希德和格伦带回了仓库。
He's given them their jobs back. He's gonna re-acquaint them with the goings-on. Yes, he tells them about Val and just really gushes on her as the foreman of the warehouse. Brandon, here's this and accuses Darryl of hitting on Val and Darryl goes, yeah, I am. Let's just get that out there. So we're all on the same page. And then Brandon starts personally attacking Darryl. Yeah. And oh, does Darryl do the right thing here? He just is like, good luck.
他让他们官复原职。他让他们重新熟悉各项工作。是的，他向他们介绍了瓦尔的情况，并作为仓库工头，对她大加赞赏。布兰登听到这些，指责达里尔在调戏瓦尔，而达里尔说，对，我就是在调戏。咱们索性把话挑明，让大家都心知肚明。接着布兰登开始对达里尔进行人身攻击。是的。哦，达里尔在这里做了正确的事吗？他只是说，祝你好运。
Yeah. Doesn't insult him back. Just lets that bad behavior just sit there with a giant spotlight on it. Just wonderful restraint. Absolutely. And now we know that there was already a moment in this day where Brandon has pushed Val aside, taken photos by himself, and now he's being sh**ty to Darryl when Darryl was just giving her compliments on her job. So you see this building for Val. Meanwhile upstairs, some of the folks in the office are going to take Andy into the conference room and have a kind of intervention. Yeah. And I say some of the people because there are people missing
是的。没有回骂对方。只是让那种恶劣的行为留在原地，并打上了一个巨大的聚光灯。克制力简直绝了。绝对是的。现在我们知道，今天早些时候布兰登就已经把瓦尔推到一边、自己跑去拍照了，而现在当达里尔只是在称赞她的工作时，他又对达里尔态度恶劣。所以你能看出瓦尔对这一切的忍耐已经到了极限。与此同时在楼上，办公室里的一些人把安迪带进了会议室，准备对他进行某种干预。是的。我说“一些人”是因为有些人不在
and it really begs the question, where is Robert? He usually works in the conference room, but he's not in there now, and he can't be in the break room because there is a portrait studio happening. He's not in the bullpen. He's running errands for his three-some later that evening. Uh-huh.
这真的让人不禁发问，罗伯特去哪儿了？他通常都在会议室工作，但现在他不在里面，而且他也不可能在休息室，因为那边正在拍全家福。他也不在办公区。他正在为当天晚些时候的3P约会采购东西。嗯哼。
He's buying all the things he's gonna need for his night of hosting. Right. We might get, right. Dwight and Angela night of hosting. Right. We might get... We might get... Dwight and Angela are in a car chase. We'll get to that. Yes, they're gone.
他正在采购当晚招待客人所需的所有东西。对。我们可能会——对。德怀特和安吉拉正上演一场汽车追逐战。我们马上就会讲到。是的，他们走了。
But I don't think that Meredith went into the conference room. Well, I don't think she'd want to attend one. You might be right. There's a very fun moment where there's a knock at the door and Andy thinks that it must be David Wallace. Yes, it is. He's ready for his delicious moment. It's Gabe. He's wearing a tiny birthday hat, I'm carrying a tiny cupcake, and he says happy birthday
但我猜梅雷迪思肯定没进会议室。好吧，我觉得她才不想参加这种活动呢。你可能说得对。有一个非常有趣的时刻，门被敲响了，安迪以为门外一定是大卫·华莱士。是的，就是他。他准备迎接自己高光时刻的到来。结果是加布。他戴着一顶微型生日帽，端着一个小小的纸杯蛋糕，他说祝加布生日快乐。
to Gabe. Nelly says, get out of here skeleton man. But now Andy's phone is going to ring, he's going to step out to take the call and it's not good news. David Wallace is stuck in traffic, he thinks maybe he'll come a different day. Andy's like, you have to come today. Yeah, I am fully committed to this bit.
奈莉说：骷髅人，滚出去。但这时安吉拉的电话响了，他走出去接电话，传来的却不是什么好消息。大卫·华莱士被堵在路上了，他觉得也许改天再来。安吉拉说：你今天必须来。是的，我对这个恶作剧投入了百分之百的精力。
You've got to come today. Then there was a moment in this group seeing that really cracked me up. It's when. It's when Andy says he's been talking to David Wallace all the time, and they're like really, like really. And yeah, but Aaron's like, it's true. Yeah, he's been talking to David Wallace all the time and they're like really like really and yeah But Aaron's like it's true. Yeah, he's always talking to him and they're like have you seen David Wallace and Aaron's like oh no I haven't and then when Toby says do you see David Wallace right now? Yeah, do you see him in the room? Yeah
你今天必须得来。然后这个群戏里有一个桥段把我笑喷了。就是当——就是当安迪说他一直在和大卫·华莱士聊天，然后他们说真的吗，真的吗。然后，是的，但艾伦说：这是真的。是的，他一直在跟他聊天，然后他们说：你见过大卫·华莱士吗？艾伦说：哦，没有，我没见过。然后当托比说：你现在看到大卫·华莱士了吗？是的，你看到他在房间里了吗？是的。
And he also keeps saying his name. Hey, Andy, yeah, we're worried about you, Andy. He's like, stop saying my name. I thought all of that was really good writing. I did too. Well, while all of that is happening up in the bull pin, there is a full-on car chase happening. Dwight has peeled out of the parking lot. Angela is in hot pursuit. We got a fan question from writer N and Idaho who said, what are the logistics of filming a car chase like this and how did you get the second car? Well, I asked Steve Berges about this writer. Basically, we did an elaborate breakdown of the shots that we needed for all of the elements of this car chase. We had to close streets.
而且他还一直在叫他的名字。嘿，安迪，对，我们很担心你，安迪。他当时说：别再叫我的名字了。我觉得所有这些桥段写得都太棒了。我也觉得。好吧，就在办公区里发生这一切的同时，一场真正的汽车追逐战正在上演。德怀特猛踩油门冲出了停车场。安吉拉在后面紧追不舍。我们收到了来自爱达荷州的莱德·N的粉丝提问，他说，拍摄这样一场汽车追逐战的后勤工作是怎样的，你们是怎么弄到第二辆车的？嗯，我向史蒂夫·伯格斯（Steve Berges）请教了这个问题，莱德。基本上，我们对这场汽车追逐战各个要素所需的镜头进行了详尽的分解。我们必须封锁街道。
needed for all of the elements of this car chase. We had to close streets. We had lots of safety meetings. We had our stunt coordinator, AI Jones on set, had to talk everyone through each sequence. Yep. Because these sequences involved not only the cars, but also all of the insert cars with cameras on them. That's right.
为了这场汽车追逐战的各个环节，我们需要这样做。我们开了许多安全会议。我们的特技协调员AI·琼斯（AI Jones）来到了片场，向每个人详细讲解了每一个镜头序列。是的。因为这些序列不仅涉及汽车，还涉及所有带有摄像机的特种摄像车。没错。
The LAPD has to come out and deal with all the traffic. It's a big deal. So Steve said this was a big one for us. It was and the car chase had more than one location. Mm-hmm. There was a lot more to it. It's in deleted scenes and in the shooting draft, I want to share with you guys two things we filmed that you don't see. First of all, when Angela is following Dwight, he pulls over on the side of the road. She pulls over behind him and he throws a diaper out the car window.
洛杉矶警察局不得不出动来处理所有交通。这可不是小事。所以史蒂夫说这对我们来说是一场重头戏。确实是大场面，而且这场汽车追逐战涉及不止一个拍摄地点。嗯哼。里面还有更多内容。在删除片段和拍摄初稿中，我想和大家分享两个我们拍了但你们没看到的画面。首先，当安吉拉在追踪德怀特时，他把车停在了路边。她把车停在他后面，然后他从车窗扔出一个尿布。
In the shooting draft it said, after Dwight throws the diaper out the window, Angela stops her car, runs after it. So I had to get out of my car on a busy street. I had to run into the side of the road. I had to find this diaper. I pick it up, I look at it, I throw it back on the ground and yell, dammit! Then it would have cut.
拍摄初稿里写道：德怀特把尿布扔出窗外后，安吉拉把车停下，追了过去。所以我必须在一条繁忙的街道上把车停下。我得跑向路边。我得找到这个尿布。我把它捡起来，看了一眼，然后又把它扔回地上，大喊一声：该死！然后镜头就会切换。
Then we both had driving talking heads, separate from one another. It would have cut to Dwight's car on the interior and he's looking in his rear view mirror saying, you think I wouldn't grab a second diaper? You always have a decoy for everything, idiot. Amazing. Then Angel was getting more and more frustrated.
然后我们俩都有驾驶时的单人访谈，互不相干。镜头会切换到德怀特汽车的内部视角，他看着后视镜说：你以为我不会多拿第二个尿布吗？你永远都为每件事备好诱因，笨蛋。太绝了。然后安吉拉变得越来越沮丧。
Here's one of those moments, and by the way, this was scripted exactly as I said it. This is how Angela Martin curses you guys. Where are you going? You GD son of a B. H. So it's a lot of letters. She doesn't say anything full out. She just has all of her abbreviations that she says very angrily. One of my bosses that I worked for who I just absolutely adored
这里有一个桥段，顺便说一句，这个台词的剧本写得跟我说的一字不差。这就是安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）骂人的方式，各位。你们要去哪儿？你们这群GD养的S的B。所以全都是缩写字母。她没有说出完整的脏话。她只是用她那些非常生气时才会说的各种缩写。我曾为之工作过的一位老板，我简直无比崇拜他，
who was so supportive of my acting career, he would let me leave secretly for auditions and cover for me with the powers that be. I was his executive assistant. When he would get really frustrated in his office, he would go, oh, fiddle sticks! He would say fiddle sticks. It was so cute. So cute. It's so cute.
他极其支持我的演艺事业，他会秘密批准我请假去试镜，并在高层面前为我打掩护。我是他的行政助理。当他在办公室里气极了的时候，他就会说：哦，竹签棍棒！（fiddle sticks!）他会说“fiddle sticks”。太可爱了。太可爱了。太可爱了。
But I knew he was real upset if he said it. Oh yeah. I'd be like, uh-oh. Son of a B. H. I know. He and Angela would make quite a pair. Mm-hmm. Let's see them argue at home. Well, the car chase is going to end and what looks like is a dead end,
但我知道只要他说这个词，他就真的是气炸了。哦，对。我会想：噢哦。养的S的B。我知道。他跟安吉拉绝对是绝配。嗯哼。真想看他们在家里吵架。好吧，汽车追逐战即将在一个看似死胡同的地方结束，
and real life it was actually a cul-de-sac. And I want to read from the shooting draft how this scene was described. Okay, great. Angela gains on the thunderbird, honking and honking. The thunderbird pulls over. Angela runs over to the car. Angela. No! She opens the door and pulls Angela runs over to the car. Angela, no! She opens the door and pulls out the driver of the car. It's Mo's exclamation point.
现实中那其实是一个 cul-de-sac（尽头式环形路）。我想朗读一下拍摄初稿中对这个场景的描述。好的，太棒了。安吉拉紧追着雷鸟（Thunderbird）不放，疯狂按喇叭。雷鸟靠边停车。安吉拉跑向汽车。安吉拉。不！她打开车门，拉出——安吉拉跑向汽车。安吉拉，不！她打开车门，把驾驶座上的人拉了出来。是莫斯（Mose），带叹号。
She starts shaking him. Angela, where is he? Where did he go? Mo's. I'm not supposed to say. Angela slaps Mo's in the face. Angela says, where is he? Where is he?
她开始摇晃他。安吉拉：他在哪儿？他去哪儿了？莫斯：我不能说。安吉拉扇了莫斯一巴掌。安吉拉说：他在哪儿？他在哪儿？
Mo's runs away. We got some fan mail about this. Angela, are you ready to answer some letter? And then we have a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a
莫斯吓得跑开了。我们收到了一些关于这个的粉丝来信。安吉拉，你准备好回答一些信件了吗？然后我们还有更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……
little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a little bit more of a the car in pursuit of the diaper. Okay. I will say this, yes and no, Ivan, because there were a lot of driving sequences, as we have shared, anything on the big open roads, that was not us. Okay. Right? But this little sort of peeling out into the cul-de-sac, where we pull up kind of side by side, Mike and I did do that. But it was a dead end cul-de-sac. There were no homes, our businesses or anything. It sort of backed up like a parking lot. So there was no other motorists that we could... Emily, yes.
更多……更多……更多……更多……更多……为了追尿布而开车。好吧。艾凡，我只能说，有也也没有，因为正如我们所分享的，有很多驾驶镜头，任何在宽阔大马路上的镜头，都不是我们自己开的。好吧。对吧？但像这种冲进环形路、我们俩并排停下的这种短镜头，我和迈克确实亲自拍了。但那是一个尽头式环形路。周围没有住宅、商业区或其他任何东西。它就像一个停车场后面的死胡同。所以周围没有其他任何车辆会让我们……艾米丽，是的。
Right, to worry about. But having said that, even us just pulling in and having to do this sequence where we kind of pull in a little bit side by side staggered, the stunt coordinator showed us exactly where the car would stop, where we would pull up to, and we had a little practice before we did any of the dialogue. I've done driving scenes like that before. We talk about as actors, sometimes in order to be on camera and focus, you have to hit a mark, and they'll put a little piece of tape on the ground.
对，要担心。但话虽如此，即使是我们刚刚把车开过来，要做那种我们要稍微并排错开靠边的镜头，特技指导也精确地给我们演示了车会停在哪里，我们会开到哪里，而且在演任何台词之前，我们都稍微练习了一下。我以前拍过那种驾驶戏。作为演员，我们经常讨论，有时候为了入镜和对焦，你必须踩到一个标记点，他们会在地上贴一小块胶带。
You'll be like, okay, when you enter this scene, you gotta stand right here or else you're gonna be out of focus. And then in these driving sequences, your car will have a mark. Yes. That is so hard to do to stop your car at the exact right place. Right, and throw it in park.
你会觉得，好吧，当你走进这个镜头时，你得站在这儿，否则就会失焦。然后在这类驾驶镜头里，你的车也会有一个标记。对。要让车停在绝对准确的位置，这太难了。对，还要挂入P档。
Make sure you throw it in park because then you gotta get out and run. And there was a camera operator between the two cars standing there. Wow. Well, Steve Urges said not to give away too many secrets, but Angela had a driving stunt double named Nancy Thurston. And Brett Jones was the Dwight stunt double. He was dressed up to look like Dwight. And drove both for rain and then also for Mike Sher. He sent a picture of Brett dressed up as Dwight. It's really great. So we can share that in our stories.
确保你挂入了P档，因为接下来你得下车逃跑。而且两辆车之间还站着一个摄像师。哇。好吧，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说不要透露太多秘密，但安吉拉有一个驾驶特技替身叫南希·瑟斯顿。布雷特·琼斯则是德 Dwight 的特技替身。他打扮得跟德怀特一样。既为雷恩做替身，也为迈克·谢尔做替身。他发了一张布雷特扮成德怀特的照片。真的很棒。所以我们可以把它分享到我们的快拍里。
And Steve Burgess said Nancy really looked like you, Angela. Like they would be, they were fooled. Sometimes they were like, wait, is Angela in the car? No, it's Nancy. All right, are you ready for your next fan question, Angela? I am. This is from Grant S in Austin, Texas, who would like to know, when Angela smacks Moe's at the end of the car chase, did Angela really smack Mike?
史蒂夫·伯吉斯说南希长得真的很像你，安吉拉。就像他们会……他们被骗过了。有时他们会想，等等，安吉拉在车里吗？不，那是南希。好了，安吉拉，你准备好迎接下一个粉丝问题了吗？我准备好了。这是来自德克萨斯州奥斯汀的格兰特·S提出的，他想知道，当安吉拉在汽车追逐战结束时掌掴莫斯时，安吉拉是真的打了迈克吗？
The sound makes it seem like it was a hard hit, and I'm not sure which answer I'm hoping for. Oh, Grant. Yes, I did slap him. Really hard. And that sound you hear from the slap is very real. They added nothing in post. But here's the deal, Grant. I didn't slap him in the beginning.
听声音感觉打得很重，我甚至不确定我希望答案是什么样的。哦，格兰特。是的，我确实扇了他。非常重。而且你听到的那个耳光的声音非常真实。他们在后期制作中什么都没加。但情况是这样的，格兰特。一开始我并没有扇他。
We did a few takes where I did a fake slap. But the camera is really close. If you re-watch that scene, the camera is really close if you rewatch that scene. The camera is right up on us. And they could just tell that it wasn't really having any effect, right? So we decided to go for it. And Mike sure was on our podcast.
我们拍了好几条，我打的是假耳光。但镜头离得很近。如果你重看那场戏，如果你重看那场戏，镜头离得非常近。镜头就怼在我们脸上。他们一眼就能看出这根本没什么效果，对吧？所以我们决定动真格的。迈克·谢尔曾做客我们的播客。
That's a fantastic interview. If you haven't heard it, it's one of my favorite interviews we have done in this whole rewatch. But we did talk quite a bit about that slap, and here is what he had to say. No, I've, I've, I hate it when there's like a fake slap on TV. I'm sure this will be fine. Just, just really hit me.
那是一次非常棒的采访。如果你还没听过，那绝对是我在这整个重看系列中所做过最喜欢的采访之一。但我们确实深入聊了聊那个耳光，他是这么说的：不，我……我讨厌电视里那种假耳光。我觉得这应该没问题。就……就狠狠地打我吧。
It'll be fine. I remember telling you that like just really hit me. It'll be fine. It'll be fine. I had no idea that you were a mixed martial arts, the professional. And you hit me so hard, I really like lost my, I did not know where I was,
没问题的。我记得当时我是这么对你说的，就狠狠地打我吧。没问题的。没问题的。我当时完全不知道你是个综合格斗……专业选手。你打得我太狠了，我真的差点……我不知道自己在哪儿了，
I didn't know what was happening, my eyes went blank and my hearing dropped out. Oh my. No idea what was happening. It was wonderful. I'm so, that's the take they used, thankfully. Because afterwards, also I remember afterwards, you were like, oh my God, I'm so sorry.
我不知道发生了什么，我的两眼一片空白，听力也暂时消失了。天哪。完全不知道发生了什么。太棒了谢天谢地，他们用的就是这条。因为事后，我也记得事后，你一直在说，哦天哪，我太抱歉了。
And I was like, no, no, no, I just didn't understand how strong you were. Oh, Angela, I remember when he told that story. I felt so bad. And I realized I'd only ever slapped one other person. And that was Rain Wilson and Castino Knight. Yeah. And so I don't think I knew how to calibrate
而我说，不，不，不，只是我没料到你力气这么大。哦，安吉拉，我记得他说这个故事的时候。我当时觉得内疚极了。我意识到我以前只扇过另一个人。那就是雷恩·威尔逊，在《城堡骑士》里。对。所以我想我当时并不知道该如何把握力度……
when they were like, okay, the camera's tight. Really slap him. What are you supposed to calibrate when they were like, okay, the cameras tight really slap them What are you supposed to do when they say really slap him except really slap him? No, and Mike was he was like, and I don't want it to look fake. I said, okay I still feel bad about it. Was that the last take though? Did you only have to do the real slap once? Oh 100% yeah, they were like we got it. Don't worry Also Mike had a red imprint on his cheek. And so they had to be like, I guess the scene is done.
当他们说，好吧，镜头很近，狠狠地扇他时。当他们说“好吧，镜头很近，狠狠地扇他”时，你还能怎么把握力度，除了狠狠地扇他？对啊，迈克当时说，我不想看起来太假。我说，好吧。我到现在还觉得很内疚。不过那是最后一条吗？你真的只需要打一次真耳光吗？哦，百分之百，是的。他们当时说，我们拍到了。别担心。而且迈克的脸颊上留下了红色的印记。所以他们不得不说，我想这场戏拍完了。
That's it. No more closeups there. Well, we should probably talk about what's been happening back in the office during this chase. We saw Kelly and Ravi pose for their portrait together. They're very much in love. Ryan's very jealous. Ravi is smitten.
就这样。那儿不需要更多特大特写了。好吧，我们大概应该聊聊在这场追逐战期间，办公室里都发生了什么。我们看到凯利和拉维一起摆姿势拍肖像照。他们俩爱得深沉。莱恩非常嫉妒。拉维神魂颠倒。
Ravi is definitely smitten. And also guess what everybody? David Wallace did show up. Yeah, he's here. He lets everyone know that Joe Bennett is liquidating Saber and they'll no longer be associated with that company. Andy sees his moment. He's getting ready for his big reveal. His delicious moment. But he gets interrupted by some very practical questions from Stanley
拉维绝对是神魂颠倒了。还有大家猜怎么着？大卫·华莱士真的出现了。对，他来了。他让所有人知道乔·贝内特正在清算赛博公司，他们将不再与那家公司有任何关联。安迪看到了他的高光时刻。他正准备迎来他的高光亮相。他那春风得意的时刻。但他被斯坦利提出的一些非常现实的问题打断了，
about is there going to be a payroll interruption? Yeah. People want more information about, you know, this whole sale. Mm-hmm. So Andy says that didn't really go how I was hoping. Yeah, he didn't get his moment. Robert is now going to come out of the conference room where I guess he has been, except for when there was the intervention.
比如发薪日会中断吗？对。大家想要了解更多关于……你知道的，这次收购的信息。嗯。所以安吉拉说……不对，安迪说事情的发展并没有达到他的预期。对，他没能迎来他的高光时刻。罗伯特现在要从会议室里出来了，我想他一直都在那里面，除了之前大家开干预会议的时候。
Right. He's going to introduce himself to David Wallace's Bob Kazamakis. Mm-hmm. I was like, what? Why doesn't anyone say, what are you talking about? This is Robert California. Also, he made a big speech at the Senator's Charity Event.
对。他要向大卫·华莱士介绍自己是鲍勃·卡萨马基斯。嗯。我当时想，什么？为什么没有人说，你在胡说八道什么？这是罗伯特·加利福尼亚。而且，他在参议员的慈善活动上发表过长篇大演讲。
Oh, lady! Amanda A. from North Carolina pointed that out as well. It was just two episodes ago. Both David and Robert attended a charity fundraiser event and Robert was a main speaker. Yeah, you know what? Nobody noticed David Wallace at this fundraiser. David Wallace didn't clock Robert California. People were out to lunch.
哦，天哪！来自北卡罗来纳州的阿曼达·A也指出了这一点。那就在短短两集之前。大卫和罗伯特都参加了一场慈善募捐活动，而且罗伯特还是主要发言人。是的，你知道吗？没有人注意到大卫·华莱士也出席了这次募捐活动。大卫·华莱士没有认出罗伯特·加利福尼亚。大家当时都不在状态。
Okay, fine. Let's say we'll suspend belief here that they didn't cross paths at that charity event. David Wallace is a good businessman. He's buying this company. Yeah. He would know who the CEO was in their name. You would think. Yeah. Can we talk about something that we teased earlier that I think has been on both of our minds, which is Darryl and Jada having their portrait taken and then Val joins them and holds Darryl's hand. But also, I'm sure Jada's like, who's a slady?
好吧，好吧。就算我们在这里暂且相信他们在那场慈善活动上没有擦肩而过。大卫·华莱士是个优秀的商人。他在收购这家公司。对。他应该知道CEO是谁以及他们的名字。你本会这么认为的。对。我们可以聊聊我们之前卖了个关子、而且我觉得我们俩都一直在想的话题吗？那就是达里尔和贾达拍了全家福，然后瓦尔加入进来还拉了达里尔的手。而且，我敢肯定贾达当时在想，这女的是谁啊？
Why she in her picture? What? What? Would you like to hear the fan mail flurry about it? Yeah. Val and C from Virginia said, does anyone else find it odd that Darrell includes Val in her warehouse uniform in his family portrait?
为什么她会出现在她的照片里？什么？什么？你想听听蜂拥而至的粉丝来信吗？想听。来自弗吉尼亚州的瓦尔和C说，有没有人觉得达里尔竟然把穿着仓库制服的瓦尔拍进全家福里，这件事很奇怪？
Yeah. Chiara V from Belgium and Caitlin M from St. Petersburg, Florida said, on my last rewatch, I realized how weird it would be for Darrell's daughter to find a picture of her father and a random woman holding his father's hand like their little family. And even if Fowl didn't have a boyfriend, I still find it super weird since Val hasn't ever met Darrell's daughter to my knowledge. Imagine how confusing that must have been for Darrell's daughter to see some strange new woman take a picture with her and her dad. It's probably supposed to be a cute moment, but I think it's strange. Am I alone in this?
来自比利时的基娅拉·V和来自佛罗里达州圣彼得堡的凯特琳·M说，在我上一次重看时，我意识到，如果达里尔的女儿发现一张照片，里面是她父亲和一个陌生女人握着她父亲的手，就像他们是一个小家庭一样，这会有多奇怪。而且就算瓦尔没有男朋友，我也依然觉得超级奇怪，因为据我所知，瓦尔从来没见过达里尔的女儿。想象一下，达里尔的女儿看到一个奇怪的陌生女人跟她和她爸爸一起拍照，心里该有多困惑。这本该是个温馨的时刻，但我却觉得很诡异。难道只有我一个人这么觉得吗？
You are not alone in it because I thought, have they met? What's Jada at the Christmas party? Was she? She was. She was at a different Christmas party. Was she at this Christmas party where Val dressed up in the dress? I don't think so. And then Darryl shows up in the tux. I don't think so. So yes, I was doing the same math of like, have they met, would Jada no Val? But even if she knew Val, they're not dating yet. We know that.
你绝对不是一个人，因为我也在想，他们见过吗？贾达在圣诞派对上吗？她在吗？她去了。她去了另一个圣诞派对。她去了瓦尔穿裙子那个圣诞派对吗？我觉得没有。然后达里尔穿着燕尾服出现。我觉得没有。所以是的，我也在做同样的算术题，比如他们见过吗，贾达认识瓦尔吗？但即使她认识瓦尔，他们也还没在交往。我们都知道这一点。
Jada would be like, hey dad, why is your friend from work holding your hand on our family picture? Yeah. Yeah. All of these things. Andy's going to go into Nellie's office. It's his office now. Well he took off his, you know, chimney sweep outfit. He's in a suit now, a very nice suit.
贾达肯定会想，嘿，爸爸，为什么你在我们全家福的照片里牵着你上班同事的手？对。对。所有这些事情。安吉拉……安迪要走进内莉的办公室了。现在那是他的办公室了。好吧，他脱掉了……你知道的，烟囱清扫工的行头。他现在穿着西装，一套非常漂亮的西装。
Yes. Still unshaven. Mm-hmm. But Nellie wants to say one thing. She's going to start quoting Shakespeare. Oh, don't bring out the bard. Don't do it. She gives a speech by Porsche and Merchant of Venice and Andy, he melts. He agrees to give Nellie a job as special projects manager. He calls her a sly bastard and he hires her back. Yes, they shake on it. Now we're going
对。依然没刮胡子。嗯。但内莉有一句话要说。她要开始引用莎士比亚的诗句了。哦，别搬出这位戏剧大师。别这样。她背诵了《威尼斯商人》中波西亚的一段台词，而安迪，他沦陷了。他同意给内莉一份工作，让她担任特别项目经理。他称她为狡猾的混蛋，并重新雇用了她。对，他们握手言和了。现在我们要
to have a scene that I can barely watch. It makes me so uncomfortable. Oh. It's like if you took all of pool party and condensed it into one scene. Yeah. I was so confused by it. I was so I had questions. I don't even want to describe it. Let's just sum it up like this. Somehow this new fellow quote unquote, Bob, aka Robert California, is going to get a million dollars from David Wallace where he's going to go study in Europe.
看一场我几乎没法直视的戏。让我觉得浑身不自在。哦。这就好像你把整集“泳池派对”浓缩进了一个场景里。对。我当时对这场戏感到无比困惑。我有很多疑问。我甚至都不想去描述它。我们简而言之吧：不知怎么的，这个新来的家伙，所谓的“鲍勃”，也就是罗伯特·加利福尼亚，要从大卫·华莱士那里拿到一百万美元，然后他要去欧洲进修。
But it sounds like his studies are just being a creeper. Yeah. On ladies, that's what it sounds like. It's like creeper 101. Yeah, he's not gonna study. He's gonna help other people get more educated because they've spent all their time being gymnasts. I don't like to speak about it. I'm gonna be honest with you. You know what? It's our Voldemort. Thank you. It's our Voldemort. We're not gonna talk about this Bob guy. Yeah, Bob is our Voldemort. We're not going to talk about this Bob guy. Yeah.
但听起来他的进修内容就是当个怪蜀黍。对。对女人们下手，听起来就是这样。这简直就是“怪蜀黍入门101”。对，他才不会去学习呢。他要帮助其他人变得更有文化，因为他们把所有时间都花在练体操上了。我不想谈论这个。说实话。你知道吗？这就是我们的伏地魔。谢谢。这就是我们的伏地魔。我们不打算聊这个叫鲍勃的家伙。对，鲍勃就是我们的伏地魔。我们不打算聊这个叫鲍勃的家伙。对。
Bob is our Voldemort. Yeah, I think there's a cut to a shot on my face in this scene and I think it says it all. All my feelings about this. What a way to write off the character of Robert California. Mm-hmm. It really undermines David Walsh's intelligence. I actually really appreciated Andy Buckley's performance here,
鲍勃就是我们的伏地魔。是的，我觉得在这场戏里有一个切到我脸部的特写镜头，我觉得它说明了一切。我对于这一切的感受。真是不错的方式来把罗伯特·加利福尼亚这个角色写出剧。嗯。这真的大大贬低了大卫·华莱士的智商。其实我真的很欣赏安迪·巴克利在这里的表演，
because I feel like it was one of those moments where maybe in the conference room, he heard it in a different way. But now as Bob, aka Robert, is explaining it to the group, I feel like you see the wheels turning, like he's hearing it in a new way. It's like way to sign it.
因为我觉得这正是那种时刻，也许在会议室里，他是从另一种角度听到这个消息的。但现在当鲍勃，也就是罗伯特，正向大家解释时，我觉得你能看出他在转动脑筋，就好像他在以一种全新的方式听到这个消息。就像是……真有你的。
Yeah. So I did appreciate that choice. Bob leaves, he's gonna give Andy a big old smooch on the lips. He says it's been a great year and he's out of there. Okay. Well, who knows if that's even his name because he's the lizard king. What a journey. because he's the lizard king.
对。所以我很欣赏那个选择。鲍勃离开了，他要在安吉拉的嘴唇上狠狠地……不对，是给安迪的嘴唇上一个大大的吻。他说这是棒极的一年，然后他就撤了。好吧。谁知道这到底是不是他的名字，因为他可是蜥蜴之王。真是一段奇妙的旅程。因为他可是一只蜥蜴之王。
What a journey. Angela, you are now gonna have quite the scene. I am, this was a big scene. Before I dive into it, I'm sure everybody noticed my mic pack at 20 minutes and 19 seconds. How could you miss it? They did, Ange. As she runs into the DNA lab testing place. So I have a lot of
真是一段奇妙的旅程。安吉拉，你接下来要迎来一场重头戏了。没错，这是一场大戏。在我深入讲述之前，我确信每个人都注意到了我在20分19秒时露出的麦克风发射器。你怎么可能漏掉它？大家确实看到了，安吉。当她跑进DNA实验室检测中心的时候。所以我有很多
memories about filming this. First of all, the day we filmed this scene with Dwight and Angela at this lab testing place, they had built it over in our warehouse, so it was right there on set. Greg was there. And you know, we didn't see as much of Greg in season eight. He was over at Parks and Rec, but he came for this day, and he was talking to Rain and I about the storyline. I have a great candid photo of him and Rain just sitting backstage talking. I'll put it in stories, I really love it. But one of the things I wanted to share
关于拍摄这场戏的记忆。首先，我们拍摄这场有德怀特和安吉拉在实验室检测中心戏的那天，他们在我们的仓库里搭建了这个布景，所以它就在片场。格雷格也在。你知道的，我们在第八季里不太常看到格雷格。他当时在《公园与游憩》剧组，但他那天特地赶了过来，他跟雷恩还有我聊起了这个故事情节。我有一张非常棒的抓拍照，拍的是他和雷恩坐在后台聊天。我要把它发到快拍里，我真的很喜欢这张照片。但我想分享的一件事是，
is that when we read this shooting draft, when we got this script, I remember being sad. I was sad because I was starting to realize it didn't seem like Dwight and Angela were gonna end up together after all. Yeah. And I had been rooting for them for so long. I really believed in this relationship
当我们阅读这版拍摄剧本，当我们拿到这个剧本时，我记得我当时很难过。我很难过，因为我开始意识到，德怀特和安吉拉到头来似乎并不会在一起。对。而且我支持他们俩很久了。我真的坚信这段关系
in the world of the show, you know? I thought they were the perfect foil to Jim and Pam. They were to me, the Mike and Holly, the Jim and Pam, you know? Yeah. And I wanted to share two scenes in the shooting draft that really made me feel like they weren't going to make it. They didn't make it into the final episode, but it felt like the writing was on the wall. Literally. This is how they read. One scene took place in the break room
在这个剧的世界观里，你知道吗？我认为他们是吉姆和帕姆的绝佳对照。对我来说，他们就是迈克和霍莉，是吉姆和帕姆，你知道吗？对。而且我想分享拍摄剧本中的两个场景，它们真的让我觉得他们俩走不到一起了。这两个场景没有进入最终播出的剧集，但感觉剧情走向已经是板上钉钉了。字面意义上的板上钉钉。它们是这样写的：一个场景发生在休息室里，
right after they got their photos taken. The Senator and Angela and Baby Philip. The Senator leaves and Angela would have said to Dwight, why won't you let go of this fantasy? Dwight says, why won't you admit the truth? Angela says, Dwight, I know this for a fact. It is not your baby. And Dwight says, how do you know?
就在他们拍完全家福之后。参议员、安吉拉和菲利普宝宝。参议员离开了，安吉拉本该对德怀特说，你为什么就是不肯放过这个幻想？德怀特说，你为什么就是不肯承认真相？安吉拉说，德怀特，我很确定这一点。这根本不是你的孩子。德怀特说，你怎么知道？
And then Angela sees through the window that the senator is returning. And I don't know if you notice this, but if you rewatch that scene as Angela and the senator and baby Philip leave, Dwight looks at them for a long time and it kind of has a deep thought on his face. In the shooting draft it said Dwight watches them leave calmly. As if Dwight is wondering as well that maybe they shouldn't be together. Then there would have been another scene that was in the shooting draft. It was part of this DNA lab testing scene and we filmed it. It was a much longer scene. Angela says to Dwight,
然后安吉拉通过窗户看到参议员回来了。我不知道你们有没有注意到这一点，但如果你重看那场戏，当安吉拉、参议员和菲利普宝宝离开时，德怀特看了他们很久，他的脸上带着一种深思的表情。而在拍摄剧本中写的是，德怀特平静地看着他们离开。就好像德怀特也在纳闷，也许他们真的不该在一起。然后剧本里还有一个场景。它是这个DNA实验室检测戏的一部分，而且我们确实拍了。那是一场长得多的戏。安吉拉对德怀特说，
Dwight, I don't think it's yours, Dwight, we'll see, won't we? And then he thinks for a minute and he looks at her and says, why not? Angela says, it's just a feeling I have when the three of us are at home together and it's just quiet and it's just us, It feels right. It feels like it's the way things were meant to be. Dwight looks at her. Does it? They sit. After a beat, Angela puts her hand on Dwight's. After another beat, he clasps her hands and they wait. And it says a stage note is, Angela seems very sincere. seems very sincere. Wow, so what that's telling me is that whatever the results are, Angela is saying to him, I feel like a family with this man. Yes, she's really saying that this is the family she wants. Yes, and in the scene description when it says that Angela is sincere, it says Dwight hears this.
德怀特，我觉得这孩子不是你的。德怀特说，咱们走着瞧，不是吗？然后他思考了一会儿，看着她说，为什么不呢？安吉拉说，这只是我的一种感觉，当咱们三个人一起在家的时候，周围很安静，只有我们俩，感觉很对。感觉事情本来就该是这个样子的。德怀特看着她。是吗？他们坐了下来。过了一会儿，安吉拉把手放在了德怀特手上。又过了一会儿，他握住了她的手，他们静静等待。剧本的舞台提示写道，安吉拉显得非常真诚。显得非常真诚。哇，所以这告诉我的意思是，不管检测结果如何，安吉拉都在对他说，我和这个男人在一起才觉得像个真正的家庭。是的，她真的在说这就是她想要的家庭。是的，而且在场景描述中，当写到安吉拉很真诚时，上面写着德怀特听进去了。
So that's how it was scripted. So you understand why I was like, sad, if you watch this scene before Dwight tries to kiss Angela in that moment happens, which was improvised by the way, that wasn't the way the scene was going to end. But I also think it needed a little bit of levity there. But right before that moment, before we hold hands, both Dwight and Angela Martin look sad, because I think it's this realization that was said in the extended scene. That's interesting.
剧本原本是这么写的。所以你们能理解为什么我会觉得难过吧，如果你看这场戏，在德怀特试图亲吻安吉拉那个时刻发生之前——顺便说一下那是即兴发挥，剧本本来不是那样收尾的。但我也觉得那里确实需要一点轻松的氛围。但就在那个时刻之前，在我们牵手之前，德怀特和安吉拉·马丁看起来都很伤心，因为我觉得他们意识到了延伸版场景中所表达的那种心情。这很有意思。
And then they cut that out. I think maybe they were wanting to make a little bit more of a cliffhanger here. Yeah, because it's the end of the season. And we do leave this episode not knowing the result. That's right. Yeah. Ultimately, this episode is going to end with Oscar at caffeine corner and the senator is going to going to make a pass. He covers baby Philip's ears and it's like,
然后他们把那段剪掉了。我想他们可能想在这里制造更多一点悬念。对，因为这是季终集。而且我们看完这一集时确实不知道检测结果。没错。对。最终，这一集的结尾是奥斯卡站在咖啡角，然后参议员走了过来，想要调情。他捂住菲利普宝宝的耳朵，然后说，
call me. And Oscar's like, oh my gosh gosh it's on great cliffhanger for season 8 I thought and you know I watched all 19 minutes of those bloopers and I want us to end with a blooper from this episode Ed improvised a song in between talking heads while he's dressed like the chimney sweep a song in between talking heads while he's dressed like of season 8. Reset was to the season 8 song one more time. Yay! Oh, thank you everyone for being on this journey with us. We have completed season 8 and we will be back now with season 9 in the new year. In the new year, 2024, season 9.
给我打电话。奥斯卡当时就想，哦天哪！我觉得这是第八季一个绝佳的悬念，而且你知道的，我看完了那19分钟的幕后花絮，我想以本集的幕后花絮来结尾。安迪在拍摄“说话头”的间隙即兴唱了一首歌，当时他正穿着烟囱清扫工的服装，在拍摄“说话头”的间隙即兴唱了一首歌，当时他穿着……第八季的重置版歌曲，再来一次。耶！哦，谢谢大家陪我们走过这段旅程。我们已经完成了第八季，新年我们将携第九季回归。新年，2024年，第九季。
We just love you guys so much. Thanks for writing in every week and we just hope you have a great one. We'll see you then. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jennifer Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jirkins. Our in-studio engineer is Sam Keifer. Our editing and mixing engineer is Jordan Duffy and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco.
我们太爱你们了。谢谢你们每周的来信，希望你们一切都好。我们到时候见。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹妮弗·菲舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的录音室工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的剪辑和混音工程师是乔丹·达菲，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·巴巴科。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》。你 这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。